okay go okay welcome everyone back to
Minecraft yeah look at this beautiful
Hey look at that what is that okay
all right it's getting there it's just a
big pillar we'll do the details after
it's gonna be glorious just as tall as
IKEA Tower to the sky and beyond baby
that's what I'm talking about today we
have a lot of things to do it's a night
right you're again that's right you're
again my favorite horse I love you so
much we're going on an adventure today
you and me yes that's right
love you love you so much I won't kiss
you coz your unholy love you better stay
in there I was gonna build a lava around
him just to make sure he doesn't I don't
know what you are to be honest but I
realized that risks the safety of man
and I cannot risk the safety of friend
so you can come today - actually I
wanted to today
why can't how do I ride horse old-school
minecraft adventure deep you stay here
and guard the thing the unholy thing I
don't oh I have an exit nice I was like
wait do I have an exit today we're gonna
bring back what I started how many
episodes I'd ago I don't know but I put
a parrot it was jacksepticeye parrot the
green parrot underneath a little thing
in the jungle because I wanted to
preserve him and then I forgot about him
so he's been there for about a couple
maybe I hunt eh all right maybe we'll
bring you back yeah so he's been there
for a couple hundred years but here we
go
yeah alright rest time rest time you eat
you eat all right keep going yeah oh no
wait I forgot my goddamn I need a boat
alright we can make a quick book dance
man I love when you teleport like that
dude so epic how is this tree huh how is
that tree explain Mojang Jesus don't go
wandering off
now you're again like your ancestors all
wasted I remember never forget II how do
you make a boat again affront that was a
trick I never forget how to away one
yeah I never forget on rigged boat you
thought I forgot cringe let's make two
boats you never know all right come here
now we can go I know you two don't do
well in what third isn't that right
Sandy's penny penny penny it will be
okay just follow my Lincoln it will be
okay I think the jungle is on this side
Frick I don't remember it's been so long
what that flip are you dude
dad bad that's what you are dumb
question don't even answer it okay
clearly I've been here before
alright in the book and the book you're
against mugging you first don't be
scared detective
what in the world is that go in do not
resist no in the bow get in yeah yeah
get in the boat yeah you did it oh my
god I'm not playing games
alright what if I said look do this get
in the boat
get in the boat alright no both to this
fine you will swim what in the world did
I build here it's so funny because it's
probably video evidence of what I did I
just can't remember all right here we go
yeah just like good old times they love
it they love love love it you can be in
the boat you know that right just so
we're clear
alright what is this what that flippin
dippin is this
I must have marked something here that's
that but we're subjunctive
look at that nether right there's the
jungle alright there's something there
we're coming for you I can burn we're
coming for you oh this is how I brought
him back the first time remember they
remember that soon when I brought you
back the first time yeah I member okay
yeah that is that place I remember that
we have a portal going there forget how
big the world is in Minecraft sometimes
glorious IKEA Tower that actually works
well to locate my base well wasn't that
a huge waste of time guys
well done well done bow for you alright
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
differently
gum Holmes me god damn that looks cool
dude never seen my base from afar never
yes never come on that's cool there's a
bed why not hate me about grabbed a
dude this place is so cool I never
realized good jump me I'm just like
rediscovering all the stuff I'd done in
the past
oh yeah is this me now remember oh yeah
yeah green IKEA bird all green let me
eat your spleen Oh little green Aki a
bird you in my turn okay oh you're so
green damn I'm a musical talent no do
you feel by it just don't spill it on
the floor it's not epic yeah let's do a
pic jump yeah see that's Ben he's super
impressed dude I can't wait to see IKEA
bird green version it's gonna be
sometimes I forget that I'm 30 years old
and I need to restrain myself what is
this this is a village oh my god there's
a whole new society year's end isn't
that amazing dad dad don't be don't be
afraid I've come to take your women and
your loot what's there only one no
children no women or children my friends
you are free live and prosper know it
losers no no judge no do the whole East
creepiest flip dude I ain't going down
there
what in the world is smelly no way I'm
going in there too spooky
oh my god there's so many no we did you
can't run but you can't gammy stop get
her son
get him son he attacked me then do it
yet useless what in the world was that
they kept you prisoner they kept him
prisoners Len hurry let's heal him with
the healing arrows
hurry I keep missing spend I'm trying to
help in oh yeah let's get going oh my
god to have to jump over no way ain't
doing it I don't like building bridges
y'all know why but sometimes you got to
do what you got to do for the people you
love god damn it look you can stop
swimming now you're again you're against
Mergen you are you're not a submarine I
told you many times many times I tell
you how many times six times you're so
bad with water it's embarrassing you're
embarrassing me it's fine
thank you a key bird there she is
you see that boys boys yeah you see that
yeah that's right it this big what's
that saying why did I kill all those
innocent villagers they attacked it it
wasn't my fault all right let's find
this flippin bird dude all right you two
have served your your adventure nests I
ain't going in there with you guys
because it's gonna be too complicated I
just want to get the bird and I'll be
right I'm sorry I'm sorry
don't cry don't cry don't cry don't cry
I just got to go to work all right let's
find this flippin bird dude it's gotta
be easy
Oh what is this oh nothing all right
Hey look there's temple hmm I do
remember it being next to a water source
yeah yeah yeah oh my god here it is here
it is here this here this here this is
it here is it here is it here
could it be could it be could it banging
Butterbean huh
No oh I got shivers I almost thought it
was a dang it
it's somewhere here I'll find you IKEA
bird number green number green you're in
green I'll find you
this is extremely important dude that's
a lot of bamboo yeah for real though I
do miss my bros fan I'm sorry we're
going together come on don't be scared
of water no I'll look at everyone's -
it's too dumb come on spin yeah we'll
find them together no problem all right
well I've been here before
yes maybe it's over there by the great
pillar let's go what do you think Sven I
think I should apologize for murdering
no here you can have bamboo all right we
don't have time to
argue we have a mission guy damn or shop
for creepers in here by the way I'll
sneak up on ya oh I think this might be
it let's get some melon he flipped in
love melon do yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes I love that part of
Charlie I saw today yes yes yes yes yes
oh oh oh here it comes this is it I
remember green IKEA bird I hear you
where are you oh you've been here so
long I go my god you must be starving
you must be so hungry I care I care
about eat eat eat eat what the flip is
wrong with you eat the melon you love
melon alright you have the seeds seeds
yeah eat the seeds yeah he's our spam
he's ours we conquered idea oh look he's
swimming oh look he can't swim oh
nevermind oh look he's trapping it's so
cute
alright set on me set on me bye I need
to prove come on oh my god you're the
worst parrot ever seriously get out of
there oh my god we did it's men we got
dam dig it dude I can't I am so sorry
about that
we're cool right I think they don't like
each other huh Sven excuse me alright
let's head out of here no my godson is
the worst swimmer of all time I keep
forgetting Dan there's so much I haven't
gone outside in so long I don't remember
anything just been like hanging around
in my base there's an outdoor wood I
can't believe he was still there I
wasn't sure honestly I was not sure I
thought they would despawn or something
but hey you hang in there man whoa
careful careful give up she says I don't
think he likes me yet but he will he
will like me there you go I don't know
what possible reason he has to not like
me I don't get it
all right get him boys am I gonna have
to put you both on leashes all right
here we go yeah nothing like a parrot
and
dog for a little swim that's right I
think I saw something here before but
I'm not quite sure
is he on me yeah look at that green
green idea Bert friends forever all
right let's bring back a new friend he
probably will resist guys but that means
he loves us even more what in the
Morley's are you stop that stop it oh no
he's falling in he can't get up smell
there's something called 9-1-1 alright
here's what I worked ok stop it
not in front his head disgusting what is
wrong with you oh they just be snacking
brah is that all you do you just lay on
your belly all day I like it that's the
kind of energy that I will kidnap all
right you're with my gang now how do I
can I not kidnap pendous I can't put a
leash on panda SHhhh
ok wait hold up how to kidnap pan this
oh wait I gotta add minecraft sorry okay
maybe you can kidnap the children oh god
you guys are weird
that does not look right ok so
apparently if you do this don't worry
guys nothing fishy going on here no no
don't push him off don't push him up
don't push him up okay now I think they
can sexy let's try it sexy
do it do it do it it's adorable look at
this dumb little thing it's so stupid
I didn't know they did somersaults I
forgot about that more babies I want
more now don't just eat I want more bit
there don't look at me I am I taming it
right now or what is happening I mean I
think he likes it Oh so if I had oh oh
my god he grew up are you kidding me oh
you know you're not pretty anymore I'm
setting this forest on fire you know
what screw the wilderness not that
important
oh my god watch out for the flames that
really took off didn't it well it's
gonna happen to all of us at some point
it's better now than your again we're
coming we're just a bit slow I think
they can both teleport
yeah we did a year again we did it don't
look over there that's fine that's
nothing happened it wasn't it was like a
screen IKEA party's crazy all right
Jurgen meet green IKEA burn look how
impressed he is yeah did you match my
goggles and now we're at home
oh no not you're not a submarine I keep
telling you bruh success only one
natural disaster cost I think I see this
as an absolute win oh wait the bridge is
over here oh let's be careful there boys
I thought I said you're free you can
leave stupid some weird spawns here like
what is that he's fine he's fine he
didn't take damage glorious bro town oh
my gosh have you can you guys stop is it
still going my machine oh and it's okay
it's alright alright let's put you back
buddy
there ya go we cannot escape from either
look deep we got a new friend oh let's
put you up on a this will do for now
let's put you up there line there oh you
can't put them there one just laying
there birds don't bad everyone knows
they stop it I just want to see him jam
out yeah
look at him go boys
yeah but you could date we should dance
when ya
stinky don't even look at in another
success it's not right and no one died
no one died absolute victory all right
guys I'm gonna in that episode they're
just kidding I have one thing to do
where's the parrot see on me you're on
me you cannot come to deny there that's
not happening actually maybe you can
come and sit now I am that's not
happening you just jump off sit sit boy
good boy how's it going in here
everything's everything No
I will not have sex with you you stinky
Smith deeply tea no don't follow me
don't follow me
sit you guard your guardian of the
Chamber of Secrets I build up the nether
a little bit it looks different now yeah
look at that ceiling I don't like it
though don't like it I prefer the fool
what are you doing with the babies here
okay get this fling it really I said no
babies I said I said no babies I said no
babies don't come to me and complain we
had a rule we had a rule oh god they're
strong oh god they're strong oh god
they're strong
oh god abort abort abort I told them no
babies we're cool right we're cool right
we're cool right we're cool right we're
cool right we're cool right yeah we are
cool that's what I thought always that
your mummy I feel terrible look how cool
that looks look a night look at this
idiots snipe them up from a distance
stinky stinky prick
I nearly died because of you
idiot cringe what did I do nothing I did
nothing but defend my honor
yeah dude I'm getting good at these log
shots man look at it yeah did you roll
dead you were all dead that daddy your
daddy will die your mommy will die your
puppy will bye-bye yeah go back in the
lava how they do spawn you you know how
the story goes all right let's let me
show you guys oh god oh god there's a
lot of them oh god they're teaming up
they're teaming up it's not fair to
teamwork oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god I got it
guys don't don't I know you're upset and
I understand I know you're upset and I
understand why but what did I possibly
do that was so bad huh keep falling up I
haven't shown you the best bit yet are
we cool alright I guess we're not God
they keep spawning day I could actually
die here this is not good this is a
little scary
oh shoot the smoothie we could have been
French you know all right let me heal my
Electra ya stupid pigs my god are you
kidding me
how they keep spawning dude guys I'm a
hundred percent innocent watch this I'll
eat while I all right I think we're cool
now I think it's in the past
isn't that right boys is in the past all
speaking of which I have so much gold
let me trade with these fools alright so
yeah we're cool look at that Alabama as
always I'll pay my taxes three melon
seeds as required bear that's it for
this week's episode next one we're gonna
bring out back another good friend of
mine I think you know who it is his name
starts with B and then Sweden
and yeah yeah yeah like and subscribe
21% of yard subscribe I'll see you guys
next time
thanks for watching in a world where
science knows no boundaries travel to
land where no tuber has been and explore
never-before-seen landscapes actors
ancestors collect ancient items
rediscover your favorite scientifically
accurate dinos what will you create